why didn't this work out it did work it
just was it was incomplete I sat down
today with the special effects producer
who created the Whitney hologram
suddenly there was more more enhancement
to the face to be done on the final
close-ups that were chosen for the TV
show because you know there is a
difference between seeing a live
performance and seen an extreme closeup
then there were people in the audience
look that were crying christina threw a
fit when she heard that there was a
possibility of the show being canceled
she's furious absolutely furious
christina released this statement today
i was honored that the Houston family
asked me to perform a duet with the
legendary Whitney Houston
sadly the technology could not meet up
to the talent that Whitney possessed
Whitney who died in 2012 isn't the first
singer to get the mind-bending hologram
treatment that's Elvis was Celine Dion
on Idol in 2007
this was actually more TV magic than 3d
hologram Presley's performance was
edited in from this 1968 comeback
special then in 2012 to pop at Coachella
in almost 5 years after his death a
Michael Jackson hologram performed at
the Billboard Music Awards and don't
count out a Whitney hologram a
production remains in the works we're
working on a full-length show that's
going to be launched later on this year
as a as a tour and that'll be a one-hour
show that will show Whitney at different
stages of her life